you're around people that say Hey money
won't make you happy I'm with you it
ain't gonna make you happy but it'll buy
a nice Villa
you can bring your kids and some support
and some staff the last thing I'm gonna
tell you is that money matters and you
got to get your money right don't waste
it don't lose it use it use it to make
yourself better if you have a business
use it to make yourself better and the
business better hire employees use it to
make yourself better the business better
to hire employees make them better and
then add more employees and then use it
to Market your company Market yourself
to reach new connections use money to go
out and meet the people that dream
bigger than you do and that have done
all these things I'm telling you which
is they're not wasting the weekends and
they're paying the price I promise you
you'll end up with a life it'll be
beyond anything you can dream or imagine
need motivation watch the top 10 with
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because in my
first business I quit on my business
partner I was making 300 bucks a month
and I didn't have the motivation to keep
going and the thing that got me through
was studying the stories of
entrepreneurs who've had massive success
and I hope that in sharing these stories
with you you find a motivation to keep
going and if I'm being honest I still
need to hours for myself today too so
today let's learn from one of the best
Grant Cardone and my take on his top 50
rules for success
enjoy
it can't just be one strategy you're no
longer just a phone person or an
in-person person or an internet person
if you're heavily dependent upon the
internet do not abandon your other mixed
choices this is like mixed martial arts
we call it mixed martial selling that's
right Mixed Martial selling I am the
Mixed Martial Arts of sales because I
use the phone I use the internet I use
social different than the internet and
number four I use a personal visit I
will walk in knock on your door
and number five I use referral so what
are your different mixed martial arts if
you will your mixed Arts of sales today
the internet's one the phone's one
retail traditional retail visits for
social media and number five referrals
influencers getting other people to
endorse you rich people do not value
money the way poor people do they they
invest money they don't spend it you
know the best the best spending is still
worse than the best in the the worst
investment like you can make a bad
investment that would still be better
than a smart spend when you spend money
you don't get an investment back
and when you invest money at least you
got a possibility I mean at the very at
the very least you get a tax write-off
so if I spend money on a belt
um I can't write it off I can only wear
it and if I invest money in a Grant
Cardone belt
and wear it on stage and it flops as a
product and nobody ever buys it it's at
least a write-off it was at least a
promotion so a bad investment is still
better than a smart spin so uh wealthy
people don't spend money they invest
money I was married to my business
um
I was not going to do this until I had
money
was that a good decision one thousand
percent or like if would if you had a
relationship not accelerated no no no no
no no no no explain that because I was
the dream I and I believed this I told
my wife when I got with her I said look
I'll do anything for you except one
thing
I will not give up on that dream if I
got to surrender my dream
I'd rather be alone
because if I abandon my dream I'll
abandon you I truly believe that I see
so many people man they give up their
dream for the wife they give up their
dream for the husband they give up their
and then and then the wife and the
husband get together and they have kids
and they give up their dream again
because of the kids and I said the day
we have kids we cannot blame the kids
for not going after our potential in our
dreams if we ever have kids when we were
getting together and she wasn't ready to
have kids she wasn't even ready for me
and and so I knew she was the right
person for me and I'm like look I'll
give you anything monogamy I'll never
cheat on you I'll never Jack around on
y'all I'll take care of you I'll provide
you with a life that you can only dream
of
this was 12 years ago I mean this is way
before Grant really hit full Grant and
and which she's really
um
added to and made it easier but
I said look if you if you if I got to be
less than who I'm meant to be to be with
you
that's powerful can't give you that
that's true so I said I got books in me
this was before I'd ever written a book
I said I got books in me I'm going to do
the biggest events in the world I'm
gonna do a TV show okay I will I will be
known by millions if not billions of
people
and I will leave a legacy
and and and that that has been with me
before I ever met you
amazing and I'm not giving that up
because if I give that up I'll give you
up also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there one of the things I built my
entire career over one thing that
probably has me responsible for more
deals more closes more companies more
business than any other single thing
I've done in my career write the deal up
okay when I'm buying real estate I've
bought and sold 750 million dollars
worth of real estate every one of them
every property I bought was a sales game
it was all a sales game first I had to
get my finances right second thing I had
to do was make a call follow the guy up
he's trying to sell a property I gotta
find out why would you sell it to me how
can I get in his circle of influence
okay how can I get their attention how
can I then follow them up to keep their
attention every real estate deal I've
ever bought
required me to follow up just to buy the
deal which is a sales job three I had to
use my mixed
pass to get the deal for I had to write
a deal up I can talk till I'm blue in
the face
there's a there's a guy I wanted to buy
his property he wouldn't respond to my
phone call so what I did was sent him an
Loi a letter of intent to purchase his
property number four if you don't get to
the right up nothing matters you guys in
retail you guys in gals in retail if
you're not writing the customer up
you're showing the product presenting
the product walking around the product
and you never write them up you will
never close the deal every deal you have
ever closed in your entire lifetime
guarantee you wrote it up you didn't
talk about it to close it you had him on
a contract on a proposal somebody had to
sign something to buy you wrote them up
I mean different people have different
ways they invest but they tend to be
more focused on the long-term
appreciation of an asset
rather than give me money this second
and and I think they get they're they're
not stuck in this get rich quick thing
it's a delayed gratification yeah
they're more like yeah I'd rather have
wealth tomorrow than Rich today
and they do have a distinction between
the rich and the wealthy the the you
know the super wealthy are looking to
create wealth beyond their own means and
needs like they're not thinking about
their kids their boat their plane I know
people think that but that's not
actually true they're actually thinking
about how do I create wealth for a lot
of people Amazon's got a million
employees
yeah now most of them only earn minimum
wage but there's some people at the
upper level of Amazon that are making
fortunes when uh covet happened in the
country shut down
I flew in I told I told my guys I'm like
hey guys I want to get rid of an entire
department 43 people and they're like
you're overreacting it's a good sleep on
it we'll talk tomorrow
okay so the next morning I called him at
eight o'clock I'm like are you guys
ready to let kill the department no
we're not I said well good kill the
department it's not your call it's my
call wow I don't need your support on it
eliminate the department there was two
reasons I did that number one I needed I
needed our attention by the way it is
the dream Department of this company
I've tried to put this department
together for seven years and failed and
I'm still going to do it it's a big
dream of mine so I had to give up a
dream of mine now this is this is one of
my principles of success dude if you
want to move give up something
wow give something up surrender
something you love like 43 people did
lose her job okay it's terrible 40
million would lose their job in the next
four months
my 43 were the first I was probably the
first person to let people go in America
training
if you're not going to train then put a
sign on your desk I quit learning a long
time ago and see how many people want to
buy from you tell your family go home
and tell your wife and your kids I quit
learning I quit reading I quit studying
I quit training I can't get any better
put on there done I'm finished I'm in
retirement early I'm going to Purgatory
I'm going to wait it out cross my
fingers and hope they bring me to sales
heaven
look you're done if you don't train okay
now I know you know this you've heard it
I hate to tell you this my boy McGregor
Connor Conor McGregor McGregor my boy
Conor McGregor okay I went and saw him
fight in New York I went and saw him
fight for one reason because I saw him
say I'm not the best this isn't about
Talent it's cause I'm obsessed I out
train everyone else I have to win so bad
I train look if you're not training that
says something about your obsession or
lack of obsession with winning I want
you to win I know your your wife or your
husband your spouse your family members
your kids your mom and dad want you to
win at the next level no matter what
they tell you
even if they tell you you're doing great
patch you in the back you know the truth
you know the truth the only way to win
is to train the only way you win is to
read the only way to win is to learn
learn more listen more learn something
new look we're in a we're in a time like
we've never been before Technologies
come and go faster than people do
things are changing like this whether
it's video you're using or social media
or snap or or short videos or videos
that disappear or videos that say or
text messaging that you can create to
push and market and brand yourself
called text messaging which I've been
using a lot
look the world's changing and if you're
saying to yourself I'm too old to learn
that well then guess what you're too old
to learn that if you can't learn
anything new just put I'm ripe and I'm
about to fall off the tree and nobody's
gonna want me look look man you got to
train every single day like your life
depends on it
train every single day I am here today
I own these four companies that I own
the studio my reputation everything is
because when I was 25 years old to the
to when I was 30 years old every single
day I trained watching video every day
I'd watch the video I'd walk in and then
I would role play and then we would do a
sales meeting every single day what were
the lessons you learned uh you know
starting from essentially zero having no
money no context no uh relationships no
uh opportunities in a town that you went
to for this show where did you realize
were the keys to actually making money
even if you didn't have any well as you
see the show you see that I actually
never make any money right so
the two girls they they actually try
they they follow three of us and the two
girls went out and got a job in the
first week
and and I'm not saying that's right or
wrong or my Way's more better or worse
but but they are strategies okay they're
they're different strategies I was not
there to get a job or to earn money I
was there looking for one thing
opportunity I never spent time looking
for money ever the entire uh 90 days
okay I'm not looking for money I was
actually looking for contracts through
the contacts I wasn't looking for money
because I knew the evaluation of the
company in the last uh segment an
evaluator will come in and determine
what my company's worth my new company
right that I created and at that point I
just need to validate to him
dude my company's worth this based on
that the entire 90 days I never touched
the first hundred they gave me and this
was to prove to people do you do not
need money like it's just it's not true
you need money you do need contacts you
need people you need these people you
need people you need the right people
though
the right people that are already in
play okay just because the guy's got
money
I remember a billionaire friend of mine
uh you know he could buy a jet
and I said hey Bob should I buy a jet he
said you should I shouldn't
meaning Grant should because and he's
way wealthier than I am he could have
bought 40 of them he's like I don't have
a place to go in mine you have a you
could use yours every day so you got to
find somebody that's in place somebody
that not just has money but somebody
wants to do more with their money
so you'll notice in the first uh 10 days
I don't spend any money I don't spend
money on shelter not on food and not on
water nothing then what I do is I end up
accumulating assets and it's unfortunate
that the viewer doesn't see this within
five days I have two vehicles one was
given to me by Discovery and the other
one was a forty thousand dollar Jeep
that I basically used
uh from Ryan this guy I met and told him
I'm gonna sell your Jeep I'm going to
drive it around town and put 10 miles a
day on it and I'm going to sell it well
that's a 43 000 asset uh my truck was
worth four grand I still had my hundred
dollars I lived in a forty six thousand
dollar RV that I was trying to sell so
yeah uh and what's the other thing I did
and I picked up ten thousand dollars to
do in a 15 partnership in the equity of
the upside of this guy's company so
literally in 10 days I was accumulating
contacts that could get me equity in the
in the important part of that story is
man go get you some equity
you know Jay-Z talks about this you're
getting you know so many of you young
brothers are getting in advance while
I'm picking up the equity okay so what
are we doing exactly so I don't think
it's magic and we're having we're having
uh Papa's been watching us what is it
called
being our Papa
yeah
with us and
so we're pulling a little prank on
mother we have a wrapped
Scarlet's arm the lower half of the arm
she probably won't find that funny but
we think it is
and so they decided to put makeup on me
because Miss Scarlets got the makeup
from a 30 year old maybe 35 year old
true and
you know your dad's out there
you busy dads that are all trying to
find the whole life balance thing
how do you make enough time for your
kids
you know the question is is is is it
really about time or is it about what
you do with them
because I tend to think it's more about
what you do with them
then can we see your makeup are we going
to try to do the same thing on you
Scarlett
oh my gosh you're going crazy huh let's
let's see how you're looking Sabrina
help me is that what we're gonna get
I helped you because so guys do you guys
want more time with me or is it or is it
is it the things we do with the time we
have which one's more important I want
more time with you you do well I feel
like we're gonna have fun if we're
together yeah yeah no matter what by the
way this is a Frank fake broken arm but
last night we watched a good movie what
was it it was called Seoul yeah did you
love it
yeah probably gonna watch it again it
was such a yeah feeling movie Jamie Foxx
was a lead voice
he was a jazz guy he was a jazzy this is
coming loose so this is the prank that
we're pulling on Mama it's not gonna run
for long because I feel mean no no it's
all right it's all right oh that's good
matches your makeup too what color
should we do father should I do right
hand as well I don't know you guys do
whatever you want to do they usually do
the hand well if you broke your hand we
would if you broke your wrist
I would cover it
I don't think so yes so the question
Scarlett that everybody wants to know is
how do you make how does a parent make
time for the kids and then
do you want more time or is it things
like this that you'll remember doing
that's right close your eyes or will you
even remember this I remember I'll
remember I'll remember I'm gonna do it
to your eyebrow can you see that I
tucked it in a little is that visible
and
do I spend enough time with you guys
that's the question okay let me give you
some answers let's get it off let's get
so we're talking to the parents and the
kids out there first of all is it hard
being a kid yes yeah is it hard being a
parent yeah which one's harder
in your mind probably
honestly adult
you think being being the parents harder
than being the kid
um I guess being a parent's harder I
understand the affirmations and mental
and be positive and meditation how about
some action yeah
you know like like I you know I have
never thought something into existence
without doing something if you were an
alien looking down at PL the United
States of America and saying okay what
is there too much of restaurants bars
and businesses there's too many of them
and then and then somebody some kid pops
up Paul pops up and says I'm going to
start a new business and and the guy
from outside the planet is looking down
there saying well that's stupid why
don't you just go two-thirds of all the
businesses in America Break Even or lose
money so what I'm hearing you say Grant
is a lot of people have the dream of
wanting to start and launch a business
but what I'm hearing you say is it's
probably a lot smarter to go find a
failing business or a business that's
breaking even jump in add value and see
if you can 10x that dude that's that's
how you get on planes that's how you you
know you go to the hospital you need
emergency care you don't build a
hospital you just go to the hospital you
want food you go to Whole Foods you want
gas you go to the gas station it's no
different in business
it's called a going concern for a reason
find a going concern that's got a brand
go in that's what I did I just went in
and added value
once I added value actually we end up
splitting off another business out of
that the only thing I can control in my
life for the things that I'm willing to
take responsibility for these Gladiators
that came here thousands of years ago
and maybe lost their lives if they took
responsibility for the match full
responsibility and I might be taking
this too far right now I don't know I
don't know what it was like to be a
gladiator in 720 740 A.D okay I can't
even imagine fighting in front of 50 000
people with the lines possibly coming
out to eat me okay but I know this you
really got to get this point carried
away you got to get it like in your head
you're an executive you're a business
owner you're a manager you're trying to
hire people you're trying to hire people
and you're like oh other people are bad
oh everybody's terrible everybody's bad
I can't find good people to take
responsibility we all have something to
do with what's going on around us you
and I authorize others to drop the bomb
look I've been robbed twice in my life
23 years old I was almost killed God
came to my house put a 45 caliber pistol
in my face hit me right here then put 70
stitches in my head and face rob me
in New Orleans Louisiana I was robbed at
a younger age I caused both of those I
was the victim in both situations on the
police report victim robbed by criminals
truth is I wasn't a victim I created
both of those wrong place wrong time
wrong people I had something to do with
that everything that happens to you is
because of you quit passing it off right
it's it's gonna rain on me right now
while I'm shooting this
dude that's my fault I could have shot
this thing yesterday when it was
Sunshine watch and read high performance
people and you will see that they always
take responsibility when their life goes
to to garbage it's when they quit taking
responsibility the greats in the world
keep track of everything when they're in
the game it when they're the Gladiator
when they're the ball player when
they're the executive of a big company
they're statitizing everything okay how
many outbound how many inbound uh what's
our closing ratio what's our right ratio
everything is measured measured your
actions and measure your results those
that don't and won't are irresponsible
and they will cause you problems
I remember as a young salesperson I was
keeping a log not on what I sold but on
what I said to people I kept everything
how many people I talked to how many
people I waited on how many people I
wrote up how many people I negotiated
with how many people I closed how many
people I talked to on the phone and also
what they said and what I said what
worked and what didn't work I was taking
responsibility this is the only way you
can take responsibility by the way
to say oh I'm I'm responsible you got to
do something to follow up the
responsibility
it's how I handle
and learned and became a professional
salesperson I handled the future by
handling by being responsible for the
present you go in that gladiator you go
in there as a gladiator in that Coliseum
okay and you don't figure out how you
lost that last fight you're gonna die in
the next one take take responsibility
even if the other guy cheated he
surprised you he shocked you he pulled
out some of the weapon you didn't know
about be prepared for the future by
taking responsibility for the present so
be responsible be the cause not the
effect be responsible even when you're
not responsible be responsible bad
things happen to good people good things
by the way happen to good people and
blame no one be responsible and remember
this you want to be great you want to be
super successful take responsibility for
everything even the things that you
could have no responsibility for I've
been a sales guy for a long time and I I
just learned early on and I was terrible
at sales 17 years old 18 19 part time
part-time sales guy was I was awful when
I finally realized that sales was the
only job I could get at 25 years old I'm
just like dude I just got to tell people
the truth because I can't do all these
tricks
the NLP LP the and look if it works for
you good whatever but the mirroring the
matching they ask a question you ask a
question the Hot Potato I've heard all
the strategies and I'm like dude I just
can't do it I'm just going to be me hey
guys I'm moving from La I'm out of work
I'm looking for opportunity I'm trying
to move my family here my name's Lewis
Curtis
uh 2008 beat me up I got to get my
family out of La real estate's
impossible I can't buy it there it's out
priced out of the market and I'm here in
Pueblo because I think there's
opportunity here and that's all I'm
looking for no handouts no help I don't
I got an old truck with me I got no
money I left my kids with you got to
have your story so this is what you got
to do to play the game one you got to be
committed
you gotta be like hey I need to learn
about real estate you can't do real
estate Bitcoin stocks like you can't do
everything it'd be great at one thing
you just be a half-assed player and all
everything
and you'll never go hard enough on one
thing to ever make you any big money you
know what I'm saying I mean if you're
going to play the crypto thing then you
need to know which crypto is going to
win they're not all going to win
and then you need to go hard and heavy
on that one thing real estate for 30
years I've been studying the real estate
game and I mean I just
I know this game now I got the eye
I'm looking for their barriers to entry
I'm looking for scarcity I'm looking for
Irreplaceable
and I'm looking for something where I
can bow you add add value to the
property without spending a lot of money
I'm gonna probably spend 150 000 on the
Landscaping of this pool
that could be worth five large to me
that's a 40 35 x return
I got to pay for it I gotta be able to
see it
I got to be able to commit to it but how
are you going to see the deal if you're
looking at everything you're not so I'm
on the ocean in Miami
I know the best property in Miami's got
sand in front of me
there's plenty of condos there's nothing
you can really do with a condo only
thing you do with a condo is get a good
price on it
and hope to sell it hope to sell it for
something later on a property like this
you could actually overpay for a
property like this if you got the eye
the eye of the real estate investor the
REI so look if you want to learn uh look
at that pelicans flying overhead man
beautiful
if you want to learn the game The Way I
Know It This is a simple simple game
okay available to men women black brown
white hispanic you name it it doesn't
matter who you are where you are it
doesn't matter what your religion or
education is okay it doesn't even matter
if you've got a credit score seriously
or money down you got to know what
you're looking for because if you find
the right deal you can find money for it
these are the things they don't teach in
school dude commit first figure the rest
out later commit first okay commit first
figure the rest out later money is an
illusion money is an illusion there's so
much money on this planet
there's more money on this planet than
our people there's more money on this
planet than there are planes there's
more money on this planet than phones
there's more money on this planet than
cattle
there's no shortage but there is a
shortage of people committed to it
there's a shortage of creativity and
strategy this is why I don't buy houses
okay this is why Brandon's seen this
presentation before okay this is my
favorite Topic in the universe
because because this this is what allows
me this is what allows me to move okay
so when I buy 15 when I take 15 million
dollars
okay I buy 60 million dollars worth of
Real Estate
15 million
buys 60 million for the real estate okay
okay
well and we we I'm not buying I'm not
buying 60 million dollar deals so I'm
buying
I'm buying I'll I'll do I'll do a
billion dollars worth of real estate
this year okay y'all can y'all look at
that number
okay this is what I'm gonna do this year
so I'm going to take 300 million dollars
this year
and I'm going to buy 1.2 billion dollars
worth of Real Estate
to me it's a good deal
I can become a billionaire
I can own a billion control a billion
dollars worth of assets
for 300 million all I got to do is
figure out how to get 300 million
dollars
goddamn this is like God this is all the
math I needed I could have learned this
in the fifth grade
don't need any any I don't need any
algebra no trigonometry calculus don't
need any of it this multiplication
leverage 300 million dollars worth of
cash buys 1.2 billion dollars worth of
real estate in America okay that 300
million dollars is going to pay me 18
million dollars a year
in cash flow
is that right I think that's right
I'm going to get paid 1.5 million
dollars every month
to control 1.2 billion dollars worth of
real estate okay this is cash flow cash
flow is what
it's Freedom baby it's Freedom it's flow
it's current it's a current currency the
word currency comes from current
if you look it up in the dictionary
current it has to move
see this right here the 1.2 billion is
not moving
that's good too though that's good
because you want something this this
illiquid that will grow right this is
the flow the flow allows me to keep the
asset until it appreciates we're looking
for unusual activity
okay there's unusual activity going on
right now
it you see it every day if you're
looking for it people are moving out of
New York
entire companies are starting to move
New Jersey they're complaining about it
okay they're pissed off at sale the
government they change the rules on
um writing your state taxes up against
your federal
now what's that called uh salt
so it used to be that I paid 13 in
California and then I'm paying 48 in in
Federal I could take the 13 off the 48.
now it's not like that now it's 13 to 48
or 38 or 39 whatever is terrible
okay so I take 300 million dollars
it's cash
it's worth the last 10 years from now
how many believe this 300 million is
worth less than 10 years
you don't need another math class it's
it's you know it's going down to value
I take the cash the trash
and I buy concrete steel and glass
where people live okay we don't buy any
retail nothing no Macy's no
Bloomingdale's maybe one day but not
today
these people have to have a place to
live when we buy this asset it is Cash
flowing
we know it's going to make us six
percent in in the first year five to
seven percent somewhere in that range we
should be paid on that deal okay so so
this is really important this cash flow
right here this cash flow is what will
get you through a contraction you have
to have cash flow to assist you through
contractions if you're not going to
train then put a sign on your desk I
quit learning a long time ago and see
how many people want to buy from you
tell your family go home and tell your
wife and your kids I quit learning I
quit reading I quit studying I quit
training I can't get any better
put on there done I'm finished I'm in
retirement early I'm going to Purgatory
I'm going to wait it out cross my
fingers and hope they bring me to sales
heaven
look you're done if you don't train okay
now I know you know this you've heard it
I hate to tell you this my boy McGregor
Connor Conor McGregor or McGregor my boy
Conor McGregor okay I went and saw him
fight in New York I went and saw him
fight for one reason because I saw him
say I'm not the best this isn't about
Talent it's cause I'm obsessed I out
train everyone else I have to win so bad
I train look if you're not training that
says something about your obsession or
lack of obsession with winning I want
you to win I know your your wife or your
husband your spouse your family members
your kids your mom and dad want you to
win at the next level no matter what
they tell you even if they tell you
you're doing great patch you in the back
you know the truth
you know the truth the only way to win
is to train the only way to win is to
read the only way to win is to learn
learn more listen more learn something
new look we're in a we're in a time like
we've never been before Technologies
come and go faster than people do
things are changing like this whether
it's video you're using or social media
or snap or or short videos or videos
that disappear or videos that stay or
text messaging that you can create to
push and market and brand yourself
called text messaging which I've been
using a lot
look the world's changing and if you're
saying to yourself I'm too old to learn
that well then guess what you're too old
to learn that if you can't learn
anything new just put I'm ripe and I'm
about to fall off the tree and nobody's
gonna want me look man you got to train
every single day like your life depends
on it
train every single day I am here today
I own these four companies that I own
the studio my reputation everything is
because when I was 25 years old to when
I was 30 years old every single day I
trained watching video every day I'd
watch the video I'd walk in and then I
would role play and then we would do a
sales meeting every single day and
immediately immediately when I was 25
years old that is what changed my whole
life my commitment to training my
commitment and willingness to sit down
every day taking a piece of data
sit down and roll play that with
somebody else okay look at my stats
every day and on the way home on the
drive home every single day I would
listen to audio on my way to work every
day I would listen audio when I woke up
in the morning I'd watch a video every
morning when I got to work I role played
every time I lost a deal I role played
what I would do differently next time to
get that deal that is a commitment my
personal integrity and ethics is why I
can sell so hard
and because I believe in my product I
believe in my investment vehicle I
believe in my company I don't trick
people screw people like 35 years I've
been in business there's not one person
in 35 years that says I owe them money
there's people that try to get stuff
from me using lawyers and but
there's nobody that can say I ever
financially damaged them in any way not
a penny foreign
[Music]
great property it's not on the ocean but
it's big about 10 000 square feet
I think they get
11 Grand a night there
it's got five bedrooms beautiful pool
Affinity pool beautiful property I mean
everything here is gorgeous you can't do
go wrong when you come down here
uh the Landscaping phenomenal's got the
natal Palms plums natal plums sort the
variegated we got massive numbers of
palm trees
hibiscus bougainvillea
but we got it all here we got the birds
of paradise we got the ginger we got the
red bugabi the purple the white
Bougainvillea the pink Bougainvillea the
orange Bougainvillea you got it all and
it's popping and rocking best months of
the year
December January February March Cabo San
Lucas welcome to Magic Cole but I'm
about to bring you into a villa this is
oleander by the way poisonous to
children I don't know if you knew that
or not and I don't know if you knew oh
look at this big guy hey bud
don't go there there you go uh I don't
know if you know this but I am a
landscape
what is it called junkie I love that
shirt just absolutely
one of the most fascinating things if I
if I wasn't into the money game I'd
probably have a big landscaping business
have you ever acted your way into a hole
I mean because you just make decisions
you ever made one too quick and it's
like oh that was the wrong one more
often than not dude I you know those my
instincts are right
um and if they're not at least I have
the
skill set to reverse quickly gotcha
because if you take a long time to make
a decision you're going to take a long
time to unwind one
say the other one so if you take a long
time to make a bad decision yeah you're
going to take a long time to unwind it
yeah right if I make a bad decision
quickly I bought a truck I'm making this
up boom I'm gonna buy that truck I've
made the decision quickly to buy it I
can also make a decision quickly to get
rid of it I bought a cullinan uh
uh Rolls-Royce Cullen has 446 thousand
dollars I bought it before my growth
conference I bought it in afternoon like
I'm gonna buy that I'm gonna put it on
stage I got it I'm like this is stupid
half a million dollars for a truck is
stupid
I sold the next day
so I bought it sold it boom I wrote it
off though right right I wrote it off
because it was in my conference
so so I'm just saying like if you get
used to taking a lot of time to make
decisions
if how you buy things is how you're
going to sell things
and how you make decisions is how your
organization is going to make decisions
first I quit using drugs
I mean the the the order everybody wants
to get better and have confidence but
the first thing you got to do is you got
to quit doing whatever's destroying your
destroying your self-esteem you know uh
I'd like to believe that I could look in
the mirror and tell myself I'm great and
and then I'd feel it but if you're
destroying yourself the other 23 hours
and 56 minutes the self-talking is going
to matter
so I had to quit doing damage to myself
um I hated myself
the worst part of my drug addiction was
how not it wasn't what just what the
drugs were doing to me in in the
hangovers and the lost time and it was
the personal
personal deprivation
and degrade that I was doing to myself
the guy's house that I'm in right now T
Boone's house he died I think he was I
don't know 89 or 90. but this guy did so
much stuff man he he would go from being
he would he grew up in poverty becomes
worth a couple billion dollars loses all
of it goes back to like a billion it's
like this guy could swing so hard but he
was very active you know he knew all he
knew all the presidential people he was
in power
and I'm not saying everybody here needs
to do that but everybody has the
potential to do that
and if you had the potential to do that
you should be in a rush to go do it you
know when we're excited about doing
something you when you go on a vacation
you can't even sleep the night before
you're like I'm gonna get up at 5am
we're gonna go to the airport you waking
up every 45 minutes is it time to go and
most people are not most people are not
doing their lives like that today
they're just kind of same thing over and
over
so
yeah man now now I'm running you know
when I was 22 I had all 40 years and now
I'm you know starting to run out of time
and I'm like oh I gotta really get in a
hurry now I'm at the hinsel castle today
Hensel Castle is a castilated mansion in
the Gothic architecture style dating
from the late 17th century some say
maybe the early 18th century I mean this
has got history here so here we are
today in Wales talking about the
attitude of service one of the great
great rules of success is to give give
the attitude of service is the rule of
success that I promise you will deliver
you at levels that you never imagined
possible it's what I built my career on
the ability to give at 100 and even more
and then keep giving nothing feels as
good as giving the more you give in life
in business in relationships the more
you will get from that relationship from
your business and from the world now I'm
not just talking about money and
presence how about energy people ask me
constantly Where Are You Gonna energy
from I get it from giving how about
money the more money I give away to
other people whether it's employees or
Charities the more money I'm going to
have it could also be love or a smile or
service or even education when you want
to learn something the best way to learn
something is to start teaching It
sharing it with other people too many
people today they worry too much about
what they get rather than what they can
give to the marketplace to their friends
to their families when I have been most
lost in my life if I go into service I
will find myself I will find my purpose
again now I know what you're thinking
right now if you don't have the money
the finances the energy if you don't
have the friends you want you're like
how can I give anything I don't have
anything to give everyone has something
to give too many people have their hand
out hey what do I get too many people
come to my office what are you going to
pay me Grant what are my benefits
where's my office where's my desk what's
my view people worry about their dumbest
little things you're always worried
about what you get and guess what when
you're worried and focused about what
you get you end up getting less if you
find somebody you want to work for work
with go to them and say hey this is what
I'm going to give you let me do whatever
you need done and I will get it done
trust me you're not going to be taking
advantage of you're going to get more
than you ever imagined give give give is
one of the great rules of success and
when you give give with sincerity and
authenticity if it's not real from you
if it's not authentic and genuine if
you're not there to give to lots of
people knowing a very few of them will
reciprocate with you and do business
with you if you don't do that with
sincerity it won't work the universe is
set up this way look at the ocean the
tide comes in the tide goes out
everything works like this you give and
you will get back you just have to trust
it and you got to get your presentation
right people know when someone truly
cares I remember the first business I
built when I was 29 maybe 30 years old I
would knock on doors hey my name's Grant
I'd like to come in and do something for
your staff to improve their sales to
motivate them to give them strategies
how much is this going to cost me a
young man before anybody knew Grant
Cardone and I said look it costs nothing
this is my way of introducing myself to
the customer not wanting something in
that moment but wanting to start and
create a relationship people would tell
me hey look are you is this legit is it
really really free people are so
untrusting why because they haven't
given themselves nothing is as
attractive as someone who is positive
and someone that genuinely wants to make
a contribution and we're not just
talking about money here we're talking
about you contributing your heart your
energy a smile look when you pass a
homeless person somebody that actually
needs help and that homeless person says
hey can you give me some money and
you're like no I'm not going to help you
how do you feel about that if you give
them something even a smile
you will feel better when you keep to
yourself when you don't take the time to
give back then the next few steps you
take after that is you start to withdraw
from people giving to others is like
making deposits in a spiritual bank
account they will pay you back in the
future where's this 10x thing come from
10x 10x came from 2008 when the economy
got crushed I I was in a completely
different financial situation
and where were you I was in Los Angeles
I lived in Atlanta Richie's house and
dude I had it made like I was living the
life you know Dre was my neighbor Leo
DiCaprio was next door I'm dropping
names down I'm bragging and I throw it
here Johnny and uh and so
um
when 2008 happened I had three companies
the first two got crushed and the third
one was just frozen it was a real estate
company and I couldn't do anything and
my hands were tied I was like I was like
I went from being
free to trapped and I said I'll never I
got to figure out what I did wrong and
rather than spending time blaming the
mortgage uh you know the mortgage crisis
and the banks gave bad loans to people
and trying to figure out was it the
clintons or the bushes that did this to
me or whatever the political agenda was
I said hey what did I do wrong this has
always got me out of trouble what did I
do wrong not what did you do to me what
did I do how did I do this to me so I
don't repeat it again every morning for
10 years I said today's the last day I'm
never going to use again
15 minutes 10 years 10 years uh nine
years and and nine years and like six
months so what was the deciding factor
that actually made you quit I finally
went you know I had to go some some
place I had to change my environment so
I went to a treatment center in
Minneapolis
um during the winter time
late late February I was 25 years old
and spent 28 days there
in an environment where nobody had drugs
I didn't have access to drugs and people
were starting to talk about okay how did
you get here they ended up putting me on
drugs in the treatment center
and I'm like I don't want the drugs dude
and they're like oh no you need it to
detox to get off I'm like this this was
30 years ago like they've really ramped
that program up now
it's the legal legal drug dealer now
it's the treatment center but but the
environment gave me at least
I was able to look around and see the
damaged drugs were causing these other
people men and women of all ages
and then that really solidified okay I'm
stopping but I needed I needed a day one
day not to use drugs because I had been
using drugs every day for nine years
nine and a half years wow and so I
needed the first day once I got the
first day I'm like I can put
together two days then my head started
clearing up a little bit 28 Days Later I
go home to Lake Charles Louisiana and
that's when the rebuilding really took
place and and I had to replace all that
drug time which was a bunch of hours
every day this is what made me the Beast
like this The Savage that I am today if
you're young whatever that means I would
quit telling people your age like I
would not lead with them or I mean I'm
only 22 don't open with that nobody
cares about your age the only thing
anybody cares about is their own age
like I've never thought how old is Rob
Moore
never ever even evenly never considered
that because I don't care how old you
are I care how old I am you know and and
that's that's a fact of life that people
you know
Alexander the Great was 16 years old he
took over Persia he didn't he didn't
send a notice hey by the way I'm only
16. you know like not something it's not
good to leave with that what you want to
lead with is your ability to get
attention
and hook somebody okay when my kids
tonight last night we were at dinner
here and these guys that I'm at dinner
with they've seen they've met everybody
you you name them if they're an American
president they met him
and this one guy looks at my daughter
Sabrina says man she is freaking amazing
she's 10.
he's like I've met them all he's like
it's an amazing human being but it's
because she knows how to communicate
right how to get attention and hold it
how to keep it I sat downstairs right
now I'm like if I was 10x bigger and
that's that would if I was 10 times
bigger right now
I would have a half a billion dollars
for the debt
551 million dollars but I only have 51
million dollars for the debt that's what
I had in 2008.
if I had because the bank called me and
said we need the whole 51 million are we
going to seize your property I'm like
dude nobody's got 50 million right right
now the world's coming to an end
had I owed a half a billion dollars they
wouldn't they wouldn't have treated me
like that they had to call me and said
how can we help you Mr Cardone want to
be sure everything's all right so I went
and told my wife I said I'm gonna write
a book called the 10x rule
and she's like what's the 10x rule the
10x rule basically is I'm going to have
a half a billion dollars worth of debt
the next time and the bank will be my
friend when covet happened I owed 1.4
billion dollars
to the banks that was 12 years ago
that's 30 times what I owed 30X
The Deco bid happened the economy shut
down the world started going crazy dude
the the the government started saying
mortgage moratorium uh eviction
moratoriums like
I had six Banks call me in one day Mr
Cardone we'd like to come to your office
see how we can work help you work
through this
get big baby okay it's the 10x rule man
the 10x rule says go big or go home no
go bigger go bigger
never go home man ain't nothing at home
looking for drugs finding drugs losing
drugs like you lose them getting the
drugs yeah find them buy them lying to
people hiding from people
uh you know it was terrible it was
terrible I did that for nine and a half
years it was awful so it's the worst
part of my life it's the darkest worst
part of my life
and so I had to crawl out and and then I
replaced literally when I was 25 years
old
I started every day with a meeting and I
ended every day with a meeting
I'd go to a Narcotics Anonymous meeting
or some kind of 12-step program for I'll
bet you I did that for
15 or 16 years so you were all in
committed I'm going to a meeting in the
morning and at night I'm either I'm
going there to help myself and I'm gonna
help somebody else every day wow 15
years yeah and then and then um that was
my form of helping people like I might
help other people that have this problem
that really kept me from going back this
guy takes the best photographs in the
world
this guy takes the best video in the
that's little Johnny the camera guy see
I had the same conversation with just
like Graham man I'd love to bring you in
man but you're not black man I said yeah
what the matter what color I am dude I
like like why we care people need
information I don't I don't look at
people I don't look at like hating I
look at money people like money look my
mother raised me to love people for who
they are
period
what cover they are who are they yeah
what is your spirit what is your soul
what is your intake yeah because this
don't mean
my money gets involved color goes away
thank you
ain't nobody ever seen an ugly
billionaire
huh I ain't never seen an ugly dog
hey man I love you man let's do some
more stuff together all right let's
please
you reached out and I got back and we're
doing it again now it's time to expand
and do it bigger you say multiply let's
multiply and for the right people you're
right these people are all paying
there's some kids there's some kids that
can't pay that need to get there first
yeah because their mom is teaching them
how to save money
blackstone's taking retirement money
it's all the whole thing's a
scam saving money at the banks
everybody can do more you know and you
don't know what you can do until you see
other people doing big stuff and and
that's why today like we started this
talking about in the past I'd look up to
people want to pull them down now I'm
like wow dude that's an inspiration yeah
and I look for people like all the way
back to Jesus is an inspiration to me
like
he left his town yeah you know I've used
that Jesus analogy him leaving Bethlehem
did he leave Bethlehem or Nazareth
now there was it went to bed something
something right so I'm like you know
what nobody would know him if he didn't
leave home I've moved from Lake Charles
to Houston Houston to San Diego San
Diego to LA LA to Miami I might move
again every move's been good for me so
you got to leave your home you got to
leave your comfort you know you got to
walk the path and you got to get a team
yeah you need you can't do anything
great by yourself
yeah and uh and and I truly believe all
of this no matter where you are today
you can do everybody can do 10 times
more than you think you can
and before you get to 10x you'll end up
changing the goal to 10 times more if I
had one thing to do over again I would
be like I would learn communication
skills speaking skills
debating skills I should have taken a
debating class
because I really don't know how to
debate I just make people wrong
you know so uh that and that's not
debating but I can play with it somehow
you know
uh but but it does more for most people
so people should I would definitely go
back at 18 back to your first question I
would go back and take debating classes
I would take uh communication classes
I'd probably learn how to code
I would definitely learn how how these
guys are creating funds
spax is a new thing
um
hedge funds
I would learn how to write do surveys
and find out hey what is it people
actually want
and I would learn how to read about
money flows and and people flows in the
internet and algorithms and all this
fascinating stuff but I would I would
only do it for one reason by the way
just so everybody's clear
okay I would only do it so I could make
a lot of money when I really started
learning from the the in the beginning
what what you learn is you're learning
from the master
you know and and so I'm I'm duplicating
and emulating then at some point you
cross over and you become the master
and and if if you're a guy like me I'm
always looking to improve everything I'm
looking for another little tweak another
little twist you and I did that with the
podcast I'm looking for that that next
thing all the time how to make something
just a little better
a little faster and so at some point I
kept studying this guy until I I was
able in the beginning I didn't challenge
anything I used
I duplicated let me install the script
that I that I learned let me use exactly
what he's telling me to do do it
uh whatever whatever I heard I'm gonna
be like I'm gonna make that work
that's going to be my stable datum and
once I could re once I could trust that
then I could build on top of it I never
yeah butted anything I got a better way
in the beginning dude until I got the
results over and over consistent results
then I started then I started teaching
it to other people then I started
learning angles you kind of alluded to
like your your belief system your
spirituality what does that belief real
quickly I mean like just you know you
put it in the words yeah that I'm a
spiritual being and you know and and I'm
in a body and and but but but but I'm
not a body I'm not a brain I'm not a
piece of meat I'm not bones I'm not five
eight I'm not 170 pounds
you know I'm I'm beyond time and and
energy and measurable units
so I'm not I'm not really Grant that's
my name that was given to my given to me
the these things that I've done the cars
that I drive that's just stuff like the
the undercover billionaire was extremely
spiritually liberating
adventure for me really how so because I
lost everything I didn't have my money
didn't have the roles didn't have the
G63 didn't have the Gulf Stream didn't
have my name dude didn't have my social
media
you know didn't have my hair didn't have
my my goodies you know I didn't have 150
people on my team I didn't have
it was me
and I'm like damn dude like I don't need
anything yeah I'm in a new environment
when nobody knows me and like it was so
empowering because I'm like I am truly
like I am capable of taking care of
myself without money without credit
cards
with just communication
you know I think even in success some
people luck up right I mean the rights
they don't know they don't know I I 100
agree with what you're saying but like
they Wonder can I do it again yeah
there's that doubt could I do it again
and you know when the when Discovery
went to help me out a little bit like
because they're producing a shot like
let's keep it real it's
I'm like I don't want your help and
they're like no no we gotta we got a
meeting for you we're so I don't want it
because for you to say it about a show
throw it in the trash I don't want it
and they're like well no they it's going
to be good TV I cannot take your help
and they're like wow we're trying to
help you I'm like yeah you don't
understand once I take your help I can't
help me
once you help me then I become relying
on your help
tomorrow I'm gonna wake up and say can
you help me three days from now and be
like hey why aren't you helping me like
like I become I become disabled Money
Follows attention when I get enough
attention money will follow it if I can
get enough people to listen to me
somebody will say hey I want to sponsor
an ad because there's so many people I
just did a deal this weekend it took
like that long because of my audience I
want to give you this much money and I
want to give you options in my company
and I'm just going to cross my fingers
and hope good stuff happens
but he sees me interacting with all
these people and converting people right
so Money Follows attention if I can get
really bright over here money will go to
that if it's a good cause if it's a bad
cause it's not going to work okay but
what happens is
the the the the attention wanes it goes
away if you can Spike the money game the
money the attention will follow again
people pay a lot of money to be in the
Super Bowl or a big soccer game right
because
there's a lot of people there so if you
can learn how about algorithms getting
eyeballs keeping eyeballs surveys
learning how to keep people's attention
man you're gonna you're gonna be
unbelievable and it won't matter how old
you are by the way I actually almost
threw away what I had learned and
created this new thing called
information assisted selling information
assisted selling well I started leading
with what people wanted rather than this
guy kind of hid it was the old school
hide it
don't avoid the price bring it up later
and that's where I really started
accelerating everything giving people
the information up front allowing you to
understand how much this watch or ring
was or car was before you even asked
about it I'd tell you it's 58 000 right
away so you want to wait to the very end
you'd say yeah look look if you're if
you're shopping for a car or a watch or
a ring or a coaching program whatever it
is
you probably want to know how much it is
I know I would this this particular
product is 58 000 it would require about
you know twenty five hundred dollars
down your payments would be about 550 a
month
um let's be sure you're on the right
product you see I've already I got the
VA the value proposition the money I got
you thinking about money right now I
want you thinking about money so that
when I showed the product
you can start making sense of it because
I can't convince you that it's worth it
um you have to convince you
yeah okay I can build value but you the
buyer is the buyer I can't be the buyer
I can only help the buyer make sense of
it I've somehow figured out
just over time that that I keep adding
these little companies
and I didn't know this it was just kind
of a mistake but all I was looking for
is I didn't want to depend on one flow
of anything okay this was the first
company this was me I was out selling
stuff picking up money
okay next thing I did was I I had a
partnership with the guy right here uh
called card the Cardone group it's in
Orlando Florida it's been a partnership
for 25 years got paid me royalty to use
my name it was passive income I gave him
a majority of the company he sat there
for 25 years and went pumped his deal
used my material okay and then we
created third company this was the real
estate
I started investing in real estate I
started buying real estate provided me
with a third flow of income now what
happened was I got fat right here
and I got
uh
what's the word
complacent
like okay I'm good started playing golf
three times a week everything's good um
you know
I'm doing great I'm Alan
okay and and and
then and then and then and then 2010
came 2008 came I was like it just took
the little three circles
I didn't have the fourth circle the
fifth Circle the sixth Circle the
seventh circle I didn't have all these I
didn't have product lineups how many of
you have card on you here let me just
see a hand didn't exist that product let
me see a hand if you have Cardone
University okay beautiful man look at
the penetration
unbelievable like like you if you want
if you want customer retention get
saturation
don't make people happy make sure they
buy you a product
I'm not interested in making people
happy I'm interested in having people on
my product
some people you can't make happy it's
impossible they're not happy people
all right so 2010 comes crushes me
I went back to selling
working on that business right there and
buying more real estate and then
creating more companies okay so that I
can start bringing good people in
you understand you gotta you gotta keep
expanding you cannot be dependent upon
one thing because that one thing can go
away everybody agree with that
one ad one promotion one person one
product one of anything what have you
learned about the art of negotiation
during you know these bigger deals for
yourself how to navigate those you know
most these deals are lost over face
they're not even lost over money they're
lost over somebody losing face I'm doing
a deal right now
you mean ego or mean like uh what do you
mean I I can't if I give you any more I
lose face
okay got you so I'm negotiating a deal
right now and I said look if I give this
guy exactly what he wants right now he
still will not do it
and they're like why is that because
he's gonna lose face so it's it's people
have to win it's almost never about just
the money it's how do I win
not just financially but how do I win
and feel good about this transaction
because I've done transactions before
where I uh supposedly one in the moment
and everybody felt terrible
so it's not a win unless everyone wins
dude everybody needs to win everybody
needs to win something like everybody
needs to feel like good about the
transaction I'd rather pay a little more
and make sure you feel good
then I pay a little less and you feel
bad because I can't do another deal with
you now
um
and I'm trying to do more deals
and then everybody's got everybody's got
a motivation everyone has a motivation
every buyer has a motivation every
seller has a motivation most of the time
it has nothing to do with the money you
you have to find the motivation
how do you do that quickly for yourself
are you asking certain questions to
figure out what that is are you just
listening to their you know without
asking them what's your motivation how
do you I could I could ask that
other than money what what you know why
what do you need what's your motivation
I could ask them straight up asking
asking those kind of direct questions
are very powerful
hey why would you pick me as a buyer
there's so many other people that could
buy this asset like that's the one I
used in the real estate game these are
100 million dollar projects once you be
the greatest YouTuber in the world the
greatest skateboarder in the world do
like something is real don't be a liar
everybody's going to know it and the
higher the food the higher up you go on
the food chain the harder it is to trick
people I don't know if I was 15 years
old today I'd be probably I'd probably
be teaching people I first I'd go after
the kid Market which really is a parent
Market I talk to parents
and I'd probably create a YouTube
channel about uh how parents
how kids can parents can get their kids
to to learn faster
and and you know maybe come up with some
tricks and hacks and ebooks and courses
to create a big audience I don't know
that I'd sell anything in the beginning
maybe I would but
but I need to create a big audience so
then later someone either someone else
or myself can sell something to them
look if it doesn't include an audience
you don't have a business so I think the
first thing people need to do is figure
out how to create an audience hey it's
been said it's been said by people for
thousands of years what you thinketh is
what you getth look behind me and you
will see dreams being made into reality
imagine that back here in London
uh I don't know a thousand years ago 800
years ago I don't actually know my
history that well none of this existed
somebody dreamed about it somebody
probably thought about wow one day we'll
have a village there one day we'll have
a city there
so today I want to talk to you about in
this
video I want to talk to you about your
dreams what you thinking about what are
you imagining
I imagine I make up in my mind that
somebody thought about a little small
Township not ever imagining that one day
there would be Towers in glass and steel
and spheres and oh my gosh a city with
what 20 million people in it literally
where all the money in the universe all
the money on this planet moves through
this city the highly successful people
dream they imagine they spend time
literally writing out what their future
might look like now I'm not talking
about when I talk about dreaming in this
segment I'm not talking about when you
sleep and dream I'm not talking about
nightmares I'm not talking about
daydreaming I'm talking about you
envisioning what your future might be
like
when you see other people and you're
like God I wish I could do that or I
wish I could have that
other people if you speak about that out
loud they're they're going to try to
talk you out of it they're going to tell
you things like oh that's too much and
that's ridiculous I thought oh I'm gonna
dream people gonna try to talk me out of
it because I had people trying to talk
me out of real estate being on stage
speaking in front of tens of thousands
of people running my own events uh
creating Millions hundreds of millions
of dollars in net worth I had people
trying to talk me out of that because I
thought that they were jealous or
envious or that they're like okay if
Grant gets it I can't have it but the
truth is most the people that were
trying to talk me out of my dreams and
my visualizations and me spending time
on actually imagining
what I could achieve they weren't trying
to talk me out of it because they
couldn't have it they were trying to
talk me out of it because they quit okay
it's crazy look it's not true when
somebody tells you you can't have
everything you want look at this look
behind me look at the ships look at the
water look at the river okay look at the
the Commerce look at the monetization
that's happening back here the new
buildings that are being built the the
the the glass and the steel and
buildings going up way higher than
anybody ever imagined possible focus on
your dreams the highly successful people
do this they think about what is
possible and then they get themselves
around other people that are dreaming
you can't just dream on your own you got
to get around other people that actually
allow your dream to breathe and helps
you with your imagination you can't
really paint okay or create art in a
vacuum you need ideas you need to see
what other people are thinking and doing
in order to see what you could imagine
or put down on paper look the fact is
you're going to get what you focus on
you're getting it right now whatever you
have today is what you focused on
thought about in your mind activated in
real life
and then reinforced on a daily basis if
you're in poverty today it's because you
probably grew up in poverty thought
about poverty think you're only poverty
think that you can only have poverty and
yes guess what that's what you had Bill
Gates said if you're born poor it's not
your fault if you stay poor yes it is
your thought that is see this is already
taking place in your life your your
dreams if you take responsibility your
dreams if you're willing to take full
responsibility for what you have right
now hey the fact is what you've been
dreaming daydreaming night dreaming work
dreaming thinking about what you've been
talking about what you've been focusing
on throughout your 24-hour period each
day is what you're getting look no
person's happy without a goal
no person is going to be happy if
they're not working on being happy
people that have faith in the ability to
reach a goal people that have faith in
the ability to win to reach a goal to
hit a milestone to achieve something
those people are happy so it's not just
dreaming it's like going to work every
day and saying hey I have a dream I have
a goal I have a Target and I want to
achieve that and I'm going to do
whatever it takes to make sure I do
achieve that you got to take a risk you
got to take risks you got to take risks
I mean that that is what an entrepreneur
does
like if and a lot of people call
themselves entrepreneurs I'm like you
you need to look up the definition okay
you are violating what the one most
important thing about being an
entrepreneur take risks because I was
talking to a guy the other day he's like
I'm an entrepreneur I'm like how much
how much Equity do you have in your
house he tells me like 200 000 pounds uh
good how much money do you have in the
bank uh 300 000. how much money you have
in retirement accounts he had more he
had like 50 times more money in all
those things than he had in his business
I'm like man you're not taking risk
you're you're actually avoiding risk
okay
so you need to go be the avoiding risk
person
so become just an investor
or Savor you got to commit first when
you know something's right folks commit
commit
go all in on the deal nobody knows what
you're what you're up to nobody knows
what's going on inside me I called my
mom that night and I said I met my wife
today and she's like have y'all been out
where did y'all go what did you do I
said no she hates me
and she's like she hates you grant it
takes two and this is what I knew from
being in business and if you're taking
notes it might be worthwhile it does not
take two to tango
it does not take two to make a marriage
and it does not take a buyer and a
seller what it takes is you
it needs to be you first you have to
decide they're selling the house and
you've got to decide that they're buying
the house before any house makes a
transaction I had to decide that she was
going to be the girl before she could
see that I was going to be the guy you
guys with me all right 26 phone calls
all of them were like hey how you doing
you know I didn't mention that she never
calls me back
I didn't mention that she was breaking
my heart every time she didn't call me I
didn't mention the fact that her best
friend said I was too short
okay
you guys know what all your objections
are don't you like her a friend said
you're too short I said just tell me
what the real deal is I got to know what
the objection is I cannot handle the
unspoken objection what is the real deal
Grant you're too sharp I said okay what
else what else you got uh you're not a
Hollywood guy she's she's an actress I
wasn't in Hollywood I'm not an actor
okay good what else you're a businessman
she thinks you're too conservative okay
what else what else you got well you
don't have a prison record
you don't have a prison record no
tattoos she like bad boys okay how many
he's here like the bad boys just be
honest
okay be honest lady over here is like
yes
I love them okay so so I just continue
to pursue her because like somebody said
earlier sometimes people change
how many of your room have changed
how many of you have changed exactly
you're going to keep changing too some
of you you're not gonna like
so so I pursued her until one day
because I know this okay and you might
want to keep this in your collection of
how you handle uh discouragement along
the way
when you get a no would you agree that
no is a version of yes
how many would agree with that
dude I mean think about it what's the
opposite of yes
what's the opposite or no
what's in between
Maybe
so I always tell people when they tell
me no I'm like don't say no say maybe
okay just say maybe oh well maybe Grant
maybe but not right now excellent
because I know no's can turn into yeses
I said no to a lot of things in life and
then done them you've walked into a
casino before I am not gambling tonight
I will not gamble you came down to Cabo
I am not drinking while I'm here
foreign
okay you some of you came down no
enriched bread while I'm here note chips
no guacamole nothing okay and as soon as
you got down here you're just like
freaking hitting shots eating guacamole
slamming it in your face right so how do
you get from no to yes
just show up in Cabo
it's a maybe right how do you get
somebody to say go go from not selling
their house to yes I will
get to a maybe and then follow them up
three parts to the real estate game
number one is the deal
a good one right here I'm in the Heights
one of the most desirable neighborhoods
in all of the 713. number one's the deal
number two is the debt you got to get a
bank that's willing to lend on that
we're working on that right now
markets insane right now now and I'm
still learning how to play that game
making connections getting relationships
with people I've had money quoted to me
at three and three three and three
quarters all the way down to two point
uh seven five and then last night got
some money quoted to me at under two
percent
insane in the membrane changes
everything in the game when you can get
your debt right the third part of the
deal is Cash Equity how much can you put
down to buy the deal so many of you out
there would be looking at deals this
size if you knew how to get the debt and
the equity but because you you think
you're short on debt in equity
you reduce the deal size or the location
or the quality of the asset most of you
are chasing the debt the equity when the
tradition should be chasing the deal
because the right deal with the right
story in the right location the right
traffic the right renter and it'll
always bring the money I'll tell you a
story I just did a deal in Boca Raton I
paid 70 million dollars for the deal
and I knew like I moved on this deal so
fast it was unbelievable because I knew
that market right I didn't have to do a
lot of research because I'd already done
the research so I still did the research
right because I'd already done the
research you know what I'm saying I'm
gonna go check out this restaurant right
now see how they're doing and
um
bought the deal closed the deal very
little due diligence by the way just
Wham
looking for reasons to buy the deal
because I knew the location we raised
the rents 500 a month already I've been
in 60 days we just had one maybe two
rent two rent uh leases come in at a
thousand dollars more than they were
before we bought them and we got great
plans for the property we're gonna do
great stuff for the tenants there
point is
when you raise the rents man guess what
you make the property better you have
more money to take care of your tenants
it improves the value of the property
and gives you some momentum in that
property
uh
and then momentum to buy more deals the
point is dude find the right deal in the
right location at the right time and the
right price the debt and equity
I call the Leonard days like I paid 69
million they're like we'll give you 60
million dollars worth of debt on that
deal based on this performance just in
the last 60 days since you took
ownership that is unbelievable that
means I only need nine million dollars
to buy the deal and I've already raised
20. again uh know your location get some
support around you uh real estate is a
team sport okay it's about relationships
about the debts about relationships
equities about relationship and it deals
with about relationships best advice I
ever received my mom said hey invest in
yourself you'll never lose
I have reminded myself of that
so many times workshops I go to uh
events that I attend where I'm going as
somebody to get educated okay books that
I've read I'm like it's not a waste of
time even even if you don't think you
learn anything it is not a waste of time
you think you think you have it that it
was a waste of time or you didn't learn
anything because you hadn't used it yet
you may use that piece of data one day
and so number one anything you invest in
time or or
or money in trying to improve yourself
you're not going to lose that the beauty
salon the restaurant the bar the bar
owner
um the consultant we've all had the
experience of resenting our customers
starting not to like them
and it's because we become dependent
upon them
we have too few if we're resenting our
customer what is that saying about us
that we're not building our brand that
we're not growing that we're not selling
enough yeah you didn't go you didn't you
didn't build the top of your funnel out
enough
because this this part of it's easy
even though you hate them they never pay
you this is the kind of stuff that goes
on they don't pay me enough they always
complain they never use the product no
matter what I do for them they and
complain okay they're never happy blah
blah blah right well the truth is those
are indications that you didn't build
your your customer base wide enough
because you now resent them your
resentment is an indication that you
rely on them too much and every time
they complain to you it reminds you
I'm too reliant on too little and and
we've all done it we all do it I've done
it uh right now I'm doing it in my real
estate I told my guy Ryan the other day
I said we're depending on this one guy
too much
and he's like why do you say that
because I'm starting to resent him
so what's the first thing we should do
what are the what's the action steps
after that when we resent our customers
you got it you got you got to understand
it's not about them it's about you
has nothing to do with them you need to
go wide you need to go get more
customers if you resent Facebook if you
if if Facebook pisses you off it is
because you were too reliant on Facebook
that's money's pretty simple too how do
you get it how do you keep it how do you
multiply it most people most people
spend their whole life just getting it
they never know how to keep it
um I mean we don't even understand basic
stuff that currency is basically uh
comes from the word current where
something is moving you don't actually
get to
have own money you don't own the money
the money is gonna go some other place
and
um so yeah it's unfortunate but we're
taught nothing on that subject how do
you build wealth and stay happy at the
same time
well number one is I don't think you
know money will not make you happy like
if you're not happy you're not happy so
it'll make you jubilant and it'll make
you giddy for a second you know if I
dropped off 100 million you know at your
feet right now it would definitely
change your attitude for a bit but
sooner or later you're coming back
you're coming back to your your your
happiness level
I've never tried to get money to make me
happy ever I've never thought oh I'm
gonna go get X money this much money and
I'm gonna somehow be happier I've never
ever
I don't even know where this concept
came from
the the connection between the two
you know I go to the gym I think I'm
gonna build muscle
I go to the water fountain I think I'm
going to quench a thirst
I go to a football game I think I'm
going to be entertained
I Get Money I never think about okay I'm
gonna get 10 million bucks
and I'm gonna suddenly be happy
now I never I never even think about
like that I'm gonna get 10 million
and then I'm gonna invest it and I'm
gonna pick up 30 million on the next
swing and I'm gonna take 30 million and
convert that to 90 million I'm gonna
take that and convert it into 270 and
I'm gonna get to you know blah blah blah
right and then what am I going to do
with it but dude I'm never thinking
about it it's going to make me happy
your biggest expense in business
[Music]
if you got a talent or you got a
business your business biggest expense
is number one your taxes
[Music]
what the wealthy know is how to reduce
their tax bill that's what you don't
know that you got to get a handle on
reduce your tax bill to literally zero
and Beyond that's right Beyond that's
where you would get tax refunds or
credits going forward to reduce your
income
tax
federal and state to zero how do you do
that
I'm going to show you
anybody can do it it's completely legal
and if you don't do it come on you're
just not you're just not following the
tips of the wealthy I didn't grow up
with wealth
I grew up and had to figure out
how to take my talent increase my income
reduce my tax bill
and then get my money to work for me
harder than I worked for my damn money
the goal is to take your earnings reduce
it to zero still have the money but take
the money
and invest it
so let's say you're earning two million
dollars a year
if you live in New York City one million
dollars of that
is going to the IRS that means you got
to figure out how to live on one million
dollars and if you're a ball player out
of that came 200 grand for an agent
another 200 Grand probably for a manager
and you're having to live on eight
hundred thousand if you buy a house for
your mother you're freaking broke again
so I'm gonna show you how to play the
game you earned 2 million okay live on
as little of this money as you can in
the beginning do not spend earned income
don't spend it what you do is you invest
it and use it in a second business and
or real property so let's say I take 200
million the state's going to take you're
still going to have your four hundred
thousand dollars go to agents and
managers you got 1.6 million dollars I
want you to invest as much of that 1.6
million dollars into real property real
property will buy you about 4.8 million
dollars worth of in this case real
estate that 4.8 million dollars worth of
real estate because it's got real
property
4.8 million dollars for instance in a
deal that I'm doing right now will
provide you with 2.4 million dollars
worth of depreciation that reduces this
tax bill of 1.6 after your managers
these are expenses
to negative 800
that can be CF carry forward into future
years that means next year if you earn
two million dollars you're walking into
that year with an eight hundred thousand
dollar
credit against your income now you need
to check with your
tax attorney
you need to check with your accountant
you need to check with your manager and
your agent but I'll promise you all four
of them are going to tell you this guy's
on to something get your earned income
earned income needs to be zero and
passive income
I need to invest in a new white board
your passive income of the
what do we say 1.6 million dollars that
we invested that we have leftover we
literally I'm I'm encouraging your
literally no watches
no houses in the beginning okay don't
spend any money on the stuff no Ferraris
take the 1.6 leverage it it'll buy 4.8
million dollars worth of real property
okay you want to stay focused on your
baseball your basketball your rapping
you want to focus on your business or
maybe you want to invest this money back
in your business and zero out okay you
want to reinvest in Furniture equipment
uh if you're a musician into a equipment
touring anything to do with your
business to grow your business literally
get your earned income to be zero the
tax bill zero is zero sixty one percent
of all citizens in the United States
last year made no contribution to the
federal income taxes your job is to make
sure that you take your earned income
because you've got a lot of talent
reinvest that money okay so that you can
be better talent and or prepare for
transition when you no longer have that
Talent so this 1.6 million dollars of
earned income after your agent and your
manager you would invest and leverage
three to four times
by 4.8 million dollars worth of real
estate that would give you 2.4 million
dollars worth of depreciation in the
first year it's a little complicated now
this is called accelerated depreciation
this is the game this is the game that
the wealthy know how to use and that's
why they tend to use
all their earned income okay some of the
biggest players in the world they pay
themselves zero one dollar a year I
think Mark Zuckerberg makes one dollar a
year but he gets stock options real
property
this 2.4 million dollars of depreciation
you get in
2021. if you use it all you'll get it
again in 22. if you don't use it all
you'll get it again in 2023 and you're
going to continue to do this every year
okay I'm going to continue to do the
same mechanism every year reinvesting
earned income okay so stay with me here
okay watch what's gonna happen this 4.8
million dollars worth of real estate
remember this it's in the Box you own
that that's your position okay this 1.6
million dollars that you invested should
provide you with about
ninety thousand dollars a year in income
accept income okay that's in year one if
you do this again in year two it's going
to get you another another ninety
thousand dollars a year in passive
income that's a hundred and eighty Grand
by year two but in year two you now have
nine point six million dollars worth of
real estate real property that should be
appreciating in value providing you and
your family with passive income now now
we're at about fifteen thousand dollars
a month in passive income and you're
starting to prepare third year fourth
year fifth year now you're at seventy
five thousand dollars a month in passive
income you're gonna exit your career
because look you got five years maybe at
Max
ball players artists you don't have
forever you're not going to be a 35-year
baseball player or basketball player so
if you start multiplying these years in
year two I'm at 180 000 in your Forum at
360. in year eight I'm at 700 Grand in
passive income per year
and that is not counting the value of
the real property which in this case if
I can take this out eight years if you
could duplicate this every year and not
get a pay raise every year eight years
eight times if we did this every year
4.8 million dollars
you've paid no taxes for eight years in
a perfect situation
and that would be 38 million four
hundred thousand dollars worth of Real
Estate
that is going up in value every year if
this just goes up three percent a year I
could take this out and I say in the
next 10 to 15 years you'll have a
hundred million dollars worth of Real
Estate
throwing out passive income most of
passive income is now
not taxed at the highest rates it's it's
somewhere as low as 19 a year where
you're paying 48 to 63 depending on
whether you live in LA or New York one
of these crazy States happiness for me
comes from doing personally yeah yeah it
comes from accomplishing things
like I experienced my happiness when
when I accomplished something I'm proud
of
so when we do a conference and I walk
away and I'm thrilled at the event we
put on the quality the lights you know
that feels good you know when my the
people around me are happy when I look
around when I'm proud
of who I'm being and doing every day you
know that makes me happy seeing my kids
my kids are I'm so proud of my kids
they're such a you know a validation
that I'm a good guy when I can't see the
good guy in me I can look at Sabrina and
Scarlett say hey dude you got to be a
good guy to produce those
foreign
[Music]
a brand because you create one great
video
you're gonna happen
so you need to create a lot of content
one one masterpiece
somebody somebody said the other day
they said I said you post that video
he's like he's not ready yet I said you
know what
a video post it's better than a video
that's perfect
post the video I don't need it to be
perfect nobody's asking for perfect okay
so this is what this is why TVs are
dying because of production on a TV show
takes so long
that by the time the TV show comes out
everybody's lost interest in it and
they're they're doing something else I
mean we have viewership on some of our
channels whether it's Instagram Facebook
or YouTube or Twitter or LinkedIn or
SnapChat we have lead we have viewership
higher than some TV channels in America
that spent billions of dollars while
they're producing while they're planning
writing scripts we're producing content
you're just
just broadcasting you know we broadcast
okay and then and then so so you can't
one Masterpiece will not beat ten
thousand
uh pieces of content
so number one number two you you need to
you need to post frequently enough to
where you almost annoy your audience
okay uh you gotta you actually have to
get them through the annoying part like
well he posted too much he's posted too
much you need to post just a little bit
more so they're like oh wow this guy's I
could I can trust him now on the other
on the other side of the annoying
is I can trust him to post okay then the
third thing is you got to keep the
content entertaining and interesting
so you're not going to know how to do
that because you post once or twice and
and whatever you're doing this year
probably three or four or five years
from now you're going to look back and
say golly that was garbage it's going to
change I promise you so you know I've
posted I don't know 6 000 videos on
YouTube uh
um I don't know what I posted on
Instagram a bunch
a couple thousand post on Instagram
um
you know I I don't know what I'm doing
most the time so just so everybody knows
there is no schedule there's no plan the
there's a commitment on a plan so the
commitment is hey we are going to tell
the world show the world what we're
doing now whether that's me or my jet or
me just buying a new car or me with my
family I've been ridiculed for all those
things he's using his kids for Instagram
I can't do my I didn't bring my kid to
the to the live show okay my kid walked
in while I was doing a show at nine
o'clock at night because she woke up I'm
not going to stop the show because my
kid walks in my life any more than I'm a
stop my life because my kid walks into
my life because you made it this far in
a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome if you want to see the
one-on-one I did recently with Grant
check it out right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there true wealth
cannot be created working it could only
be created in best Elon Musk is
completely invest
he has no cash and no houses